kyle i can't believe seeing you already
dude
i mean i know i know the fact that colin
after the doubles put you up in rohan
i mean when you one of you guys are
gonna go home and then austin became the
replacement and you kind of gave up
kyle why why did you fight
oh it was so tough we pushed so hard
for the replacement to be vic i mean it
was our only chance we thought
for both of us to stay i knew if austin
went up i was going to be the target
and then it was kind of an uphill climb
just because i obviously didn't have a
connection with austin
and i didn't want to do anything that
would be detrimental to her game and
throw her under the bus so
i mean eventually i did campaign for
myself to stay in the game
without kind of talking about her but um
it was just a little too late
yeah you knew you were going home we
felt it watching you you
knew it and that moment when keeper
announced that he put you up and you
you you confronted him and then vic got
involved it got intense i mean
what happened what was the repercussion
of all that and why did you go to kiefer
to talk to him about it
well yeah so honestly with that's whole
thing i mean kiefer the whole game
preached how
good of a guy he was how you know he's
god's gift to earth and
how good his word was so when he put up
austin
obviously someone i'm close with and
just i knew that he made a deal with her
in the hoh
to not have her brain touch the block so
i was just calling him out like what is
it man like
are you is your word good are you the
best guy in the world or is this just
all an act
and i thought it needed to be done
obviously vic got involved not knowing
the full story of what happened so
yeah kind of stepped away but i think
everything blew over well with her and
yeah i don't know what kiefer's doing
well yeah and you talk about austin like
you guys are close friends you became
very close and we saw
an incredible chemistry between you two
i'm sure you're being asked about it but
was there that chemistry between you two
yeah i think there was i mean it was a
little bit slow burning i think
um it wasn't right out of the gates and
it was unfortunate that it was like the
last
week or two and the block did bring us a
little closer together
but um i think if i were to stay in this
house i think you would have saw that
relationship develop a little more
unfortunately i'm not there but we'll dm
her when she comes out right
yeah i'll slide in i'll slide in
and you said that your goal was going
into this game is to win right
to win the hoh that didn't really happen
so
did you try to change your strategy in
different ways like what
what how would you explain your game
oh my god it was a wreck i feel like we
were i feel like
i feel like me and ro were in so much
drama from the get-go i mean
the pretty boys rumors the rumors were
coming out for the girls
there's a house meeting that we were
involved in like the latoya thing
it was just so much that happened for us
so quick and it was pretty frustrating
because
our name got thrown out like so many
times of nowhere
um early and i mean i think the culprits
were
we're probably getting thai and i mean
looking back maybe i'll see differently
but
um yeah i feel like we were behind the
eight ball where
kind of we needed to win and i was just
i sucked in the comps which is something
going in i didn't think i'd do
and yeah it was unfortunate yeah that's
a mental game
and the fact that you guys came through
isolation and they went to this house
you got to meet new people which you
haven't done in a long time
um how was your mental status like how
did it play with your emotions being in
that house
honestly for myself um i thought i
handled it pretty well the emotional
stuff um
you know what a long time ago i might
have been a more high and more low
person but i think as i've gotten older
i'm kind of more of that that even keel
now
and you know that happens with with the
lessons you learn in life so
i mean this was just another step in
that and i mean it does it's it does
mess with your emotions a lot i mean
yeah
i felt like me and ro were at the top of
the game and then the bottom of the game
and the top of the game at the bottom of
the game and you hear your name
so it does mess with you a little bit
but it was such a great experience
and then we got to see you guys partying
with some drinks and thai food and
chicken
and what was it like for you to be part
of the most diverse house guests
in big brother franchise oh it was
unreal i mean
i know i'm the the white stereotypical
guy but
um but your perspective is important
because this
is a you know it's a test it's a project
exactly and i mean it felt special for
me to be that
that guy on that cast um and hear
everyone's stories
and just where they've come from i mean
i think big brother did a great job of
casting
people from so many different walks of
life and
it was just great getting to know
everyone and do you think roe rose gonna
get far
i honestly do i think him austin and
braden can kind of turn the ship around
depending on who wins this next hoh i
think is super super important
um hopefully they can pull it out for me
who do you want to win season nine
i would love i would love one of roe
austin or brayden to win
win the season i mean as you guys
probably saw those were the three that
that i was close with in the house
and developed that over the last couple
weeks so
those were some emotional goodbyes and
it sucks but
uh i'm sure i'll talk to them soon not
too soon
and who do you not want to win that
might be obvious too
jed ty kiefer beth
no no you gotta pick one pick one who's
the one person
you just can't have them win season nine
well i'd honestly i'd say keeper but i
don't think he has a chance
so maybe i'll say time okay
and what was it like to be in a bedroom
sharing a bed with
with a stranger yeah i mean i started
off
uh bed bug bed bunking with tai
and yeah then uh then me and rose
relationship developed and we thought
it'd be funny just to get the the
bromance going for a little sleepover so
uh it was all a good fun uh part of the
experience and i loved it
we love watching you on the show so
thanks for being part of it and talking
to us
and it sucks that you're out of it
because i thought you were going to go
fairly far
with us we were hoping for that
chemistry to build and watch and
all of that but uh thank you for
chatting with us today
yeah thank you so much